the tyrant Sullivan was only a young
sorcerer when he left the painting
arendelle is another world a sanctuary
that pulls forlorn beings from the
outside and gives them a home they find
conflict in the sameness and they find
comfort in the rush imagine growing up
in a place like this surrounded by
beings that have lost everything
in the outside world Sullivan alone had
lost nothing so ironically in this place
of belonging he did not belong so it's
no surprise that his Envy inspired
terrible ambition for as Sullivan would
prove there's a lot to fear from a man
nothing to lose so a young sorcerer with
spells and frost he left and never
returned
where have you called three-time cool
with you two it was cold outside huh
are the lower dark moon lies an all
London city of the gods
so the still aerosol nestled in the
boreal valley and yet even further below
past the dungeon cells of aerosol is the
ruins of a once proud capital the only
human kingdom who has ever been ruled by
a giant actually but his story doesn't
matter he left nothing of worth behind
except perhaps this the profaned flame
profane fur it defies the law of fire
and never goes out profane for it has
the abyss hidden within it and profane
or it corrupts the hearts of men
offering power of inspiring evil soul
ohon items say stumbled upon this place
when he was yet a young sorcerer it's
not uncommon to see sorcerers out on
distant journeys of discovery and I'd
bet that when he left the capital he was
not the same man
for from here on out a burning ambition
is said to have taken root within him
and considering the nature of this flame
I think we can take that quite literally
so with a great sword and perhaps a
heart profaned by the flame
he left his sights set on Erie Phil for
Sullivan dismayed this rotting world was
just like the one he had left
at this point in our story and Orlando
was still a city of the old gods one of
the most resilient cities in the world
for it
and the old royalty who resided there
remained largely unchanged throughout
multiple links of fire it was home to
the children of Gwyn himself sister
Guinevere with her Silver Knights her
brother Gwendolyn captain of the dark
moon nights and his half-sister yoshika
the crossbreed power emanated from the
Cathedral which was patrolled by the
Silver Knights and guarded by own steam
and smoke two famous knives of Gwyn the
time would come
however when on steam left the Cathedral
in search of Gwynn's firstborn child
making smoked the last night to remain
at his post guiding the ruined Cathedral
there are also beacons of the way of
white which have a sect here in aerosol
headed by Archdeacon will McDonald far
away though many more of this order toil
in the Cathedral of the deep devoted to
maintaining the age of fire that Gwyn
began here great and terrible beings are
put to their final rest and just now in
our story a powerful plant named Aldrich
have just been sacrificed to the first
flame becoming a lord of cinder back in
aerosol also the order of the dark moon
night led by the dark sun gwyndolin
swear there oaks the blue phantoms are
bound to become a shadow of father Gwyn
and the shadow of sister Guinevere
hunting down any who would threaten the
champions who linked the fire
and it was this order the dark moon
nights that the sorceress Sullivan saw
fit to infiltrate and we know this
because he was presented with the great
sword of judgment a ceremonial sword
representing the judgement of the moon
it glows like the blue of the dark moon
but much deeper if you were to look more
closely at displayed then you would
realize that it's magic is far closer to
sorcery than any existing lunar power
for Salah Han did not draw his power
from faith like the other night did but
he drew it instead from sorcery which is
an art that is despised by the old
royalty and perhaps that's for good
reason for sorcery would ultimately be
the downfall of the way of white the
dark moon night and then the gods alike
when the old world is rotten you blown
it away
and so the pontiff's usurpation of anor
londo began with gwyndolin the dark moon
nights were once led by my elder brother
the dark sun gwyndolin but he was
stricken by illness and leadership of
the night fell to me then Sullivan
wrongfully proclaimed himself pontiff
and took me prisoner
oh where could my dear brother be
Yoshika the last remaining night s of
the dark moon order mentioned that it
all began when her brother fell ill she
doesn't blame his illness on Sullivan
but you and I both know that either he
or his subordinates weren't above using
poison for it was not only the dark moon
nights
affected by Sullivan's influence the
holy deacons also were baffled from
within
Archdeacon McDonald a prominent member
of their Order who resides in aerosol
committed a grave trespass he began to
channel his faith for sorcery
transforming symbols of ecclesiastical
authority into catalysts of deep soul
sorceries from MacDonald these
stagnating Souls and the magic derived
from them represented the glorious
bedrock of this world their order was
intended to deal with the great and
terrible beings that came to them but
inevitably they were affected by the
terrors that came into the cathedral
this treason was not kept within aerosol
no McDonald also imparted deep soul
sorcery to Archdeacon Royce and his
deacons who all resided in the cathedral
and he added new dark pages to that home
of miracles literally corrupting his
order against the very flame that they
had sworn to protect he was undoubtedly
collaborating with sorceress Sullivan
who himself had his new knights infected
and empowered by the deep dark magic
erupt from their throats drawn towards
life and their very weapons became eaten
away by the tiny biting insects that
feed on those close to the deep this
force in aerosol wielding the profaned
flame nor that by the deep headed by the
archdeacon's and the
if became an evil that pushed the entire
royal family out of their ancient home
however some residents clearly escaped
all of this trauma because later far
away in a city named lauric it is said
that there is another Queen revered as a
goddess of fertility and bounty just
like Guinevere once was but back in Anor
Londo
now with pontiff's a LaVon fully in
control the true atrocities could begin
many in arizal were enslaved and as you
can see were pushed forward as fodder by
the pontiff's fire witches the less
fortunate were turned into beasts for it
is said that men who peer into the black
eyes of Sullivan are transformed look
closely at the faces of the dogs at the
hair of the spider women at these rib
cage basis that pray when they're
defenseless Sullivan forced out the
beasts hood within men especially in
those who would become his outrider
knights the most notable of the outrider
knights was the dancer of the boreal
valley her Aurora veil is actually an
artifact of the old gods committed only
to be worn by direct descendants of the
old royal family and before she was
controlled by Sullivan the dancer was
likely a daughter of Guinevere as she
has a fragment of her mother's soul
however she was clearly left behind as
the rest of her family escaped to
lothric when captured the pontiff
ordered her to serve first as a dancer
perhaps to shame her or entertain him
then he made her an outright a knight
giving her a ring of his right eye that
he knew would transform her she became
an enchanting Beast as death her armor
fusing with her own hide never far from
the fleeting dancer was bought the
outrider knight who received the
pontiff's left eye ring clearly there
was something between them some bond
shared but they would never return to
aerosol but like all the outrider
knights their spirits can sometimes be
seen roaming the old city together
in total five outrider knights were
dispatched to lothric one guarding the
road of sacrifices the second in the
basement of lothric castle
the third skulking in the grand archives
and the two most unique nights vote and
the dancer guard the main exit and
entrance to lothric Consulate's so their
placement is no coincidence
Sullivan may be back in aerosol but he
knows that the last stages of the royal
family have a presence in lauric and his
arms are all over their failing Kingdom
watching as the royal family desperately
struggles to produce an heir to the
linking of the fire waiting as he knows
that when they fail oldrich will be
raised once more as a lord of cinder
who do you think he'll be indebted to
when he rises from his grave to this end
Sullivan protected the gate - IRRI fill
with an old trick from the painted world
a magical barrier was erected repelling
everything and everyone accepts those
with a message from a small doll
wherever you go it says the moon still
sets in aerosol wherever you may be
aerosol is your home Sullivan or the
Deacons placed one of these dolls in
Aldrich's coffin and waited and
eventually of course he came for where
else would he go oldrich had spent a
long time ruminating on the fading of
the fire for him it inspired prophetic
visions of a new future an age not of
fire but of deep seas he knew the past
this world would be arduous but he had
no fear for he would become not a mere
devourer of men but a devourer of gods
and so imagine his pleasure when he
found one waiting for him in his new
Cathedral gwyndolin
son of Gwyn and former captain of the
dark moon night if I wish you were here
I would be most pleased for you both to
meet as most assuredly with you
but Aldrich wasn't the only being
resurrected you put the contest
achievement to shame
rolling over him with the help of either
black hand got hard
velorek the pale shade fell on door or
honoring for Horus the pontiff made many
enemies and they were his downfall
in the end here you have a man who
stopped at nothing to change the world
he mastered sorceries of frost miracles
of the moon partnered with a kingdom
ending flame and took advantage of the
deep he used all of this plus social and
political manipulation to usurp an
age-old kingdom rising within the ranks
of its knights twisting its beacons to
feed a god to a lord of cinder and
supplant the age of five the tyrant
Sullivan tore apart many bonds but was
undone in
by a mere and kindled who proves that no
champion is more powerful than the fire
linking cars so if this man can't change
the world then what hope do we have
[Music]
you